ever since Lexus first rolled out the is
it's been one of the Toyota luxury
divisions premiere models more than a
million in three generations have been
sold globally in 17 years this Lexus was
developed especially for the European
market and now it's been given a
makeover car testing eNOS Paisley says
the is is facelift only changed a few
small details a touch or two on the
exterior a new concept for the switches
and a new safety package also new is the
suspension it gives the driver a more
direct contact with the road and makes
driving a bit more fun
we tested the hybrid model the 300h it
currently accounts for a good 90% of all
is sales whether hybrid or turbo
gasoline variants the facelift hasn't
affected the powertrain
but enhanced aerodynamics have reduced
average fuel consumption by a marginal
tenth of a liter per hundred kilometers
[Music]
the axles shocks and chassis have been
retuned for a stiffer suspension this is
the principle difference to its
predecessor this together with new
software for the variable gear ratio
steering adds up to more responsive
steering the F Sport variant we tested
also features adaptive suspension
[Music]
that's hot eNOS recalls that the
suspension and the road feedback had
always been subject to criticism so was
a good decision for the engineers to
start there
now she's glad to be testing the sports
variant with the sport suspension and
she can't find anything about the road
feedback or the steering to complain
about in response to her very directly
and leaves her with a positive
impression on the outside only a few
details have been changed the spindle
shaped grills waistline has shifted
upwards and the visual focal point moved
downwards the air intakes and running
lights are new and a little removed from
the headlights
the head and tail light technology is
entirely in LEDs now
the palace of Venus explains that the
cars Japanese soul is expressed in tiny
details and described by the term Takumi
which means high craftsmanship she
points out the leather dashboard over
the instrument cluster with decorative
stitching and the wooden applications
worked with a special kind of laser
technology Lexus is also has a new ten
point three inch display and the
adaptive suspension brought with it an
additional mode allowing the driver to
set the cars character according to
personal preferences
phoebus recognizes the little joystick
from the last version of the vehicle but
the to enter buttons left and right are
new they send off whatever the operator
enters the idea is to make it more
intuitive and easier to operate
[Music]
[Music]
enos has a positive overall impression
of the facelift on every point
she thought the design of the front had
always been fairly offbeat and now it's
even more so the concept for the
controls has simplified them a
noticeable improvement and the
suspension makes driving more fun so all
in all
she'd call it a success in Germany the
new Lexus IS 308 starts at about 38,000
500 euros